L'ottimizzazione classica è un passaggio fondamentale negli algoritmi quantistici classici
come il variational quantum eigensolver o il machine learning quantistico.
Tuttavia, spesso risulta difficile minimizzare
funzioni complicate in spazi di parametri ad alta dimensionalità.
Mi chiamo Victoria Lipinska e in questo video esploreremo
le routine di ottimizzazione classica per gli algoritmi quantistici classici.
I problemi di ottimizzazione non sono semplici.
Quando il numero di parametri cresce, cresce anche il numero di possibili
combinazioni di valori, e cresce in modo esponenziale.
Negli scacchi, per esempio, ci sono 64 caselle
e ogni giocatore ha 16 pezzi; dopo che ogni giocatore muove un singolo pezzo,
si hanno 400 posizioni diverse. Dopo due mosse 72.084 posizioni,
circa 9 milioni dopo tre e circa
280 miliardi dopo quattro mosse.
Se arriviamo a sole 40 mosse, il numero di posizioni possibili
è stimato intorno a dieci alla potenza di 120.
Giocare una partita perfetta richiederebbe di esplorare tutte le posizioni possibili
e questa crescita enorme significa che scorrere
tutte le posizioni una per una è impraticabile.
Questo si può risolvere suddividendo il problema in due sottoproblemi più piccoli.
Prima di tutto, dobbiamo determinare quali configurazioni della scacchiera
è probabile che compaiano nei passi futuri della nostra partita.
Chiameremo questo il nostro sottospazio di interesse.
E secondo, dato quel sottospazio, dobbiamo determinare qual è la mossa migliore.
Chiameremo questa la nostra mossa migliore.
In questa analogia, la ricerca iniziale nel sottospazio di interesse
è l'analogo del nostro algoritmo di ottimizzazione classica.
Una volta che quel sottospazio di interesse è noto,
un algoritmo quantistico è di solito responsabile di trovare la mossa migliore,
dato quel sottospazio.
Iniziamo considerando un solo parametro,
theta, che parametrizza una funzione di costo che vogliamo ottimizzare.
Se tracciamo il grafico della funzione, diciamo che assomiglia a qualcosa del genere,
sull'asse X abbiamo i valori del parametro theta
e sull'asse Y c'è la funzione di costo.
Tieni presente che la funzione di costo potrebbe essere un costo finanziario reale
che vogliamo minimizzare, o come spesso accade nel variational quantum
eigensolver, potrebbe essere un'energia minimizzata dalla natura.
Il nostro obiettivo è trovare il theta
che corrisponde al costo minimo.
Partiamo da un valore iniziale di theta e a ogni passo di ottimizzazione
troviamo un nuovo theta che riduce ulteriormente il costo.
Sembra facile capire in quale direzione procedere sul grafico, se riusciamo a vederlo.
Ma la difficoltà nell'ottimizzazione è che in realtà non possiamo.
Scopriamo solo il costo, cioè un piccolo frammento dell'intero puzzle,
una volta che valutiamo la funzione sul theta scelto.
Questo è il funzionamento generale dell'ottimizzazione.
L'ottimizzatore campiona i parametri theta e calcola il costo.
Come puoi immaginare, scegliere casualmente il parametro theta per ricostruire
l'intera topologia della funzione non è molto efficiente.
Invece, quello che fanno gli ottimizzatori intelligenti è calcolare
il gradiente della funzione a ogni passo.
In questo modo l'ottimizzatore sa in quale direzione sul grafico
procedere per trovare il costo minimo.
Una volta che il gradiente è zero, l'algoritmo termina
e il minimo è trovato.
Questo minimo potrebbe non essere il minimo globale.
Potrebbe essere un minimo locale,
cioè il valore più piccolo della funzione di costo nel vicinato
ma non sull'intero intervallo di theta.
Nel caso di un parametro, è certamente possibile.
Tuttavia, più parametri abbiamo,
più la funzione diventa complicata.
Già nel caso di due parametri abbiamo una superficie,
e nel caso di quattro, non riusciamo nemmeno più a disegnarla.
Proprio come nell'esempio degli scacchi, riprodurre tutte le possibilità
diventa rapidamente intrattabile.
Vediamo che è difficile minimizzare
funzioni complicate in spazi di parametri ad alta dimensionalità.
Tuttavia, per ottenere risultati ragionevoli, vogliamo che le routine di ottimizzazione classica
siano sia veloci che accurate.
Devono anche essere robuste al rumore,
che avrà un effetto significativo sui computer quantistici di prossima generazione.
Gli algoritmi di ottimizzazione classica possono essere ampiamente suddivisi
in due classi: metodi di ricerca diretta e metodi basati sul gradiente.
I metodi basati sul gradiente richiedono informazioni sul gradiente
della funzione durante il processo di ottimizzazione.
Questo può essere calcolato analiticamente
o approssimato con un calcolo alle differenze finite.
I metodi di ricerca diretta non usano informazioni sul gradiente
e adottano altre strategie per minimizzare la funzione di costo.
Alcuni degli algoritmi di ottimizzazione più comunemente usati
nel campo del quantum computing sono i seguenti ottimizzatori.
COBYLA sta per constrained optimization by linear approximation
ed è un algoritmo di ottimizzazione privo di gradiente.
SLSQP è sequential least squares programming,
un algoritmo di ottimizzazione basato sul gradiente.
Usa un vettore di perturbazione stocastica
per calcolare simultaneamente un gradiente approssimato della funzione di costo.
In un ambiente privo di rumore, ottimizzatori come COBYLA
e SLSQP risultano convergere più velocemente di SPSA.
Gli ottimizzatori classici hanno i propri parametri
che puoi specificare per casi particolari, ad esempio la dimensione del passo.
Questi si trovano di solito nella documentazione relativa
al singolo ottimizzatore.
Ti consiglio di consultare l'elenco di riferimenti qui sotto per un confronto
degli ottimizzatori classici più aggiornati.
Esploriamo un altro fenomeno collegato
all'ottimizzazione classica di circuit quantistici parametrizzati.
Come abbiamo visto, un gradiente nullo della funzione di costo può indicare
che l'ottimizzatore si è ritrovato su un plateau privo di caratteristiche interessanti, il cosiddetto
"barren plateau."
Un barren plateau può essere il risultato di molti fattori.
Il gradiente della funzione di costo corrispondente a un circuit quantistico
con parametri inizializzati casualmente
decade esponenzialmente a zero con il numero di qubit.
Questo perché lo spazio quantistico esplorato dall'ottimizzatore
diventa esponenzialmente grande all'aumentare del numero di qubit.
I modi per affrontare questo problema includono la riduzione del numero di parametri
e quindi della dimensione dello spazio sottostante.
Un altro modo per pensare all'origine del problema del barren plateau
potrebbe essere la natura agnostica al problema del circuit parametrizzato
di fronte a uno spazio di parametri esponenzialmente grande.
Progettare un circuit in modo su misura per il problema considerato
potrebbe essere una buona soluzione.
Oltre allo spazio di parametri esponenziale che induce i barren plateau,
anche altri fenomeni fisici possono generarli:
il rumore e la decoerenza presenti negli esperimenti di quantum computing,
l'espressività complessiva del circuit parametrizzato,
o la non-località e il grado di entanglement della funzione di costo modellata.
Affrontare queste sfide rimane un'area di ricerca attiva.
Avendo ora esaminato i componenti principali del VQE,
riassumeremo l'algoritmo nel prossimo video.